what's up guys I'm Tim Gettys i'm here
with greg miller and i'm looking at no
man's sky ooh here's the problem what
the bottom greg i like hello games I
appreciated joe danger I think they're
very nice gentleman I speak to them
quite often through email about working
with them on this game that's the one of
the caveats here okay number 2 i'm
incredibly excited about no man Scott I
think this game looks really really neat
and I can't wait to play it it looks
fascinating here's where we get into the
problems I'm sick of this kind of demo
yeah I've been getting this no man's sky
demo quite a bit hey let's jump in the
ship hey we're here now look at all this
cool stuff all right let's land oh hey
the universe is huge let's go over there
we land over here hey there's like a
dinosaur guy over there let's check if
there's any resource here all right back
in the ship what is this game about what
the hell's going on I don't know Greg I
don't know and I don't know if we'll
ever find out because when we first saw
this same demo last year essentially
yeah I was like whoa this looks really
cool and they close sony's conference
with it last year right yeah that's
that's crazy yeah yeah so it was a big
part of it yeah yeah I'm pretty sure
that's what it ended up ok and I
remember being like wow this is like a
cool looking game yeah this looks crazy
this is next-gen yeah and now I look at
it and like all those things still
remain right those are all still true
statements but now what exactly what are
we doing what are we planted the fear I
have is like yeah you know that he says
he's Sean here says you know that we'll
get a release date soon thank you know
it's time to get the release date
already I want to know what how far out
this is because if you remember we used
to work at another place yes there was
in this is before the plane crash
claimed everybody who worked at that
place but Marty if you remember this
Marty kid yeah may he rest in peace
after his playing crowd huh he had said
that this was the most fascinating game
that will never come out mmm cuz he's
like there's no way they can do it but
they keep doing it so he believes in
them they're clearly positioning this
even though it's coming to pc to be a
PlayStation 4 exclusive yeah console
exclusive here I'm in yeah I want to
play it Colin give me horny in five
minutes with it call made a really good
point in saying that this could be a
game that comes out this year ya next
year
the year after that yeah and all and it
all makes sense because it's like all
right I don't really know what this is I
still don't think this year is the case
cuz you would have pulled the trigger
here yeah you would have said hey I know
that everyone's worried about
Playstation force fall since we have no
real exclusives so heads up knowing sky
is coming out yeah well here it is done
this also doesn't seem like a fall game
to me but I mean like the way Sony's
Sony's pushing this team is on oh oh ya
mean ya they need to have something
there what are they standing on right
now it's going to be all third-party
stuff now granted it's a fantastic year
for games oh we figure we had Witcher we
have Batman you're gonna get metal gear
in September and then now you get
Fallout and there's still the Uncharted
collection right stealing the Charter
collection you get fallout though in
November you really like this the thing
is like if this came out anywhere near
fall out I'm not playing no man's sky so
they have no real reason to shove it out
other than the fact they want to make a
point that we have games we hate
exclusives and don't buy an xbox but no
matter how many times I see Devils like
this that are very similar this is still
super cool the moment when you go from
space on to the Sharon and see all the
things just can't even hear you see all
these objectives and it's beautiful in
your cockpit like I want to I want to
just get a day with this game okay 30
minutes of this game customized my ship
and go around I just want to find the
dinosaurs he talks in here right of like
oh yeah you know there's fighting and
there's this it's like what can we see
that you know I feel like we have
observed other battles I don't think
we're getting into them we're getting
that tactile feedback and what it's all
like or what even the point of the game
is if it's just that I'm gonna try to
explore as many planets as possible so
that when you one day run into one a
mine or somebody else runs and they're
like oh man Greg Vaughn is playing it
cool cool cool man yeah Greg's out here
exploring the licorice that lacks the
satisfaction I feel like that sounds
cool in theory but really its gonna feel
like when you get something liked on
facebook where it's like all right you
didn't even leave a comment yeah he does
i wonder if I don't knowing it's gonna
be when you get you think you're getting
two new planet you find that Nick
Scarpino is there yeah I mean that's a
side of me sarpinos bag yeah Nix Nix
thought on this trailer he was just like
so it looks like the boring parts of
mass effect everybody Nick don't listen
to Nikki's trying to run over here we're
gonna wrap this up instead ladies
gentlemen this is no man's sky you're
watching all of you three cover
John games become more intimate / on
side quest bullsh Nick Scarpino hates
video games he hates them